[Music]
no idea
in this film we wanted to kind of strip
it back and wanted have more fun with it
you know I'm tyka had the exact same
idea and we were both saying things for
Ragnarok it's trying to have more
attitude
Ragnarok sort of a new cycle on the life
of the world or the realms of the
universe it's the destruction of the
old' and the rebirth of the new Nets
really exciting to me surprise this will
be such fun the way that I've approached
this is to rebuild it in a new way look
great dude totally I think it's just
perfect mix for where the character and
story need to go you know different
costumes different weapons different
cast or characters to work or give you a
different energy Thor has been a crisis
he never went back to Asgard to claim
the throne he wanted adventure when we
pick him up he's at the end of this
search for himself when the ones we
survive this trip I'd say the odds
million fund
[Music]
you know I wanted to take people on a
ride and and inject some comedy into it
and adventure that keeps people laughing
along the way
it also has inspector color on the stuff
that it gets people excitement he's a
fighter